pas alors nous allons en
[Rires]
avoir il n'y aura pas que des sénatrices
il Yvo la parité il y a au moins un
sénateur qui va venir ah ben moi je
rêverais que beaucoup d'hommes
s'intéressent à la condition des
[Rires]
femmes comment il faut
faire compris sur la condition
[Rires]
des
bon donc mes chers collègues sans plus
attendre nous nous allons démarrer donc
nous auditionnons ce matin monsieur Éric
Dupont Moretti garde des saau ministre
de la Justice monsieur le ministre c'est
la première fois depuis le
renouvellement sénatorial que nous vous
accueillons au sein de la délégation au
droits des femmes du Sénat mais nous
nous connaissons bien puisque vous êtes
un interlocuteur naturel de la
délégation sur les sujets qui sont au
cœur de ces compétences la lutte contre
les violences conjugales et contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes
nous vous avions auditionné lors du
précédent trienna le 7 juillet
2021 et nous avons personnellement
beaucoup échangé dans le cadre de
l'élaboration du plan rouge juif sur
l'amélioration du traitement judiciaire
des violences intrafamiliales que j'ai
corédigé avec notre collègue député
Émilie
chandlerur encore aujourd'hui vous
m'associez régulièrement au suivi de la
mise en œuvre des mesures proposées et
je vous en suis
reconnaissante concernant la lutte
contre les violences intrafamiliales
beaucoup de dispositifs existe déjà il
faut désormais les déployer pleinement
et en faire bénéficier le maximum de
victimes la question de la formation des
forces de l'ordre et des magistrats au
traitement des violences est cependant
toujours au cœur de nos préoccupations
j'y ajouterai même d'ailleurs la
violence la la violence excusez-moi la
formation de tous les acteurs y compris
de du secteur social je pense également
que l'absence de coordination
interministérielle dans le suivi de
l'application des mesures de lutte
contre contre les violences peut être
préjudiciable vous le savez s'agissant
des moyens consacrés à cette politique
vous savez également que je plaide pour
la création d'un fond dédié à la lutte
contre les vifs afin de ne plus entendre
de la CAF je n'ai pas de ligne pour
financer ça ou du ministère de la
Justice je ne financerai pas ça tout
seul trouver un autre partenaire et en
gros effectivement vous connaissez
mon ce que je souhaite c'est une
politique pilotée avec un fond
dédié au-delà des vifs il y a d'autres
sujets que je souhaite aborder avec vous
ce matin dans un premier temps la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes notamment le traitement
judiciaire des plaintes pour violence
sexuelle alors que les plaintes pour
viol donnent rarement lieu à des
investigations poussées le suivi par les
procureurs qui en ont la charge qui ont
en charge la direction des enquêtes
pourrait être renforcé encore très
récemment lors de la Journée nationale
de lutte contre le sexisme le 25 janvier
une avocate nous a indiqué que la
première question posée par un policier
à une de ses
clientes venue déposer plainte pour viol
a été avez-vous pris du plaisir pendant
l'acte je vous le recommande non mais
elle était très bonne celle-ci
aujourd'hui on le sait d'après des
chiffres publiés par le HCE en octobre
2022 moins de 10 % des victimes de
violence sexuelle déposent plaines 80 %
des plaintes pour viol sont classées
sans suite 1 % de ces plaintes
aboutissent à une condamnation
judiciaire dès lors comment mieux
qualifier poursuivre et condamner ces
violences sexuelles pourriez-vous nous
dresser un premier bilan du traitement
des affaires de viol par les cours
criminales départementales c'est un
débat que nous avons eu aussi leur mise
en place a-t-elle permis de mettre fin à
la correctionnalisation des viols un
débat est en cours sur la définition
pénale du viol nos collègues de la
délégation au droits des femmes de
l'Assemblée ont d'ailleurs entamé une
mission sur le sujet et une modification
de la définition européenne du viol
fondé sur le consentement est en
discussion au Parlement européen quelle
est votre position sur ce débat je vois
je pose la question mais je sais que ça
céit une question qui intéressait l'une
de nos collègues
également autre sujet que je souhaite
aborder ici le projet de loi
constitutionnel relative à la liberté de
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse il a été adopté par nos
collègues députés par un vote solennel
mardi 30 janvier sera examiné au Sénat
d'abord en commission des lois le 14
février puis en séance le 28
février j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire publiquement et nos récents travaux
sur l'état du droit et de l'accès à
l'IVG dans le monde en novembre dernier
nous le laisse penser même en France la
liberté pour les femmes de recourir à
l'IVG n'est pas imuable et pourrait un
jour être menacé je suis donc à titre
personnel favorable à la
constitutionnalisation de cette liberté
il me semble également que les droits
sociaux et humains les plus fondamentaux
comme celui pour une femme de disposer
de son corps ont vocation à être inscrit
dans la
Constitution monsieur le ministre
peut-être pourriez-vous nous donner
quelques éléments de calendrier
s'agissant de la convocation du
Parlement en congrès qui a un petit peu
fait tousser le Sénat si ce texte
constitutionnel était adopté dans les
mêmes termes par les deux assemblées et
nous rappeler l'intérêt de la
formulation retenue
enfin je souhaite vous interroger sur un
point plus technique qui concerne les
travaux en cours de la délégation aux
droits des femmes sur les familles
monoparentales nous avons notamment été
sensibilisés aux inégalités de
procédurees dans le traitement
judiciaire des séparations familiales
qui peuvent déboucher sur des modalités
disparates de calcul de pensions
alimentaires or le montant moyen d'une
pension alimentaire aujourd'hui qui est
de 170 € par mois est loin de couvrir la
moitié du coût de l'éducation d'un
enfant qui est de l'ordre de 750 € par
mois donc divisé par 2 c'est 375 si je
ne m'abuse et donc 170 effectivement on
est loin du compte si la mise en place
de l'ARIPA agence de recouvrement et de
l'intermédiation des pensions
alimentaires a constitué un réel progrès
en matière de versement effectif de la
pension une sensibilisation des juges
familiaux au risque de précarisation des
Mar qui élèvent seul leurs enfants nous
semble indispensable puisque je le
rappelle 41 % des enfants vivants dans
une famille monoparentale sont sous le
seuil de pauvreté contre 16 % des
enfants vivants dans une famille dont
les parents sont en couple monsieur le
ministre je vous laisse sans tarder la
parole et je proposerai après votre
propos introductif à mes collègu
d'intervenir bien merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames les
cénatrices messieurs les sénateurs à
venir non je veux d'abord vous dire que
c'est un grand un grand plaisir pour moi
d'être parmi vous ce matin et de
vous
retrouver en cette année
nouvelle petite parenthèse l'officier de
police judiciaire qui dit à
une qui demande à une victime si elle a
éprouvé du
plaisir pardon ça n'est pas mon
périmètre mais je me demande franchement
ce qu'il fait dans la
police et quand j'entends ce que vous me
dites les oreilles du mon tomb et je
pense
que si les choses se précisaient et
qu'elles étaient transmise à Gérald
hermanin je pense qu'il n'hésiterait pas
une seule seconde à tirer les
conséquences qui méritent d'être tiré
d'un tel
comportementement insupportable
d'entendre des choses pareilles
aujourd'hui ce qui signifie au fond est
c'est une transition comme disent les
commentateurs
radiophoniques que le combat n'est pas
terminé et qu'il reste encore beaucoup
de boulot à faire et que le chemin est
encore long donc je suis ravi de de de
reprendre avec vous ce ce dialogue il
est
indispensable naturellement je connais
votre engagement
total madame la
Présidente Mesdames les
sénatrices et on va je vais essayer de
répondre le plus complètement possible
aux questions que légitime euh vous me
posez bon votre délégation est pour moi
une interlocutrice si j'ose dire
absolument et et et une partenaire
absolument
privilégiée et euh je vais en venir tout
de suite au sujet qui nous mobilise et
qui nous
préoccupe la protection des droits des
femmes passe évidemment
euh en matière de justice par la lutte
contre les violences faites à le
rencontre
alors les bilans sont sont encourageants
mais les mots doivent être
mesurés personne ne peut faire de de de
culturisme judiciaire évidemment
et une violence
féminicide c'est toujours une violence
et un féminicide de trop là aussi c'est
une évidence les travaux parlementaires
récents permett de souligner qu'en
matière de violence
intrafamiliale on est engagé de manière
irréversible pour faire reculer ce ce
fléo
indigne et je vais me concentrer si vous
le voulez bien sur les chantiers
résolument
engagés mon CAP est clair ma
détermination est totale il faut
détecter
plutôt pourquoi je le dis parce que la
justice évidemment ne peut pas
intervenir si elle n'est pas saisie si
elle n'est pas alertée si son attention
n'a pas été
attirée il faut protéger les victimes
tout au long de la procédure tout en
développant simultanément bien sûr la
prise en
charge renforcer des
auteurs cette lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales repose désormais sur des
réponses et sur des réformes qui sont
profondes et qui sont effectives al je
vais vous annoncer d'abord que en
2023 le nombre de drames
évités grâce au bracelet antiraapproch
franchement a été multiplié par 3
passant de
3634 en 2022 à près de
10500 interventions des forces de
l'ordre que je veux
évidemment remercier c'est autant de
femmes sauvées
d'enfants d'enfants
sauvés toujours sur
ces pardonnez-moi sur ces outils de de
protection téléphones grave danger ont
eux aussi permis d'éviter 2500 drames en
2022 les ordonnances de protection ont
également permis de sauver des vies
elles étaient prononcées bon vous le
savez en 42 jours c'est désormais 6
jours et ce sera dans quelques jours pas
dire dans quelques heures 24h grâce à
votre proposition madame la Présidente
de en cas d'urgence euh urgence détecté
par le procureur de la République alors
par ailleurs une avancée majeure vient
d'être votée à l'Assemblée nationale
grâce au groupe modem s'agit de rétablir
une justice patrimoniale
euh ce texte sera prochainement soumis
au Sénat l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et la lutte contre les
violences conjugales euh se doivent être
menés sur tous les fronts ce t texte
permet de
d'éviter que l'auteur d'un homicide à
l'encontre de son
conjoint puisse bénéficier du régime
matrimonial on avait déjà réglé la
question de l'héritage et voyez parfois
les choses que l'on a sous les yeux et
qui sont
évidentes au fond il a fallu que l'un de
vos collègues disent
mais le bénéfice du régime matrimonial
personne ne ne se dit que il est
impossible qu'il vienne bénéficier à
l'auteur d'un
meurtre et ce texte évidemment emporté
l'adhésion du garde des saau aussi parce
que c'était tellement logique et
tellement évident que personne ne
l'avait vu et donc ce texte a été porté
par moi avec enthousiasme et il a fait
l'objet d'un consensus très très large
et je pense que on retrouvera le même
sensus devant votre
assemblée tous les champs de
l'intervention judiciaire doivent être
exploité absolument tous et c'est cette
approche
globale autour d'une même situation
familiale qui est
consacré dans les textes de novembre
2023 qui portte évidemment création des
pôle vif dans toutes les juridictions
dans tous les tribunaux dans toutes les
cours d'appel
ce texte est effectif depuis la mise en
place de ces pôles
[Musique]
spécialisés est désormais une réalité
depuis le 1er
janvier cette réforme a
été particulièrement bien accueilli
euh par les magistrats
euh grâce aux travaux préparatoires qui
ont été conduits dans la mission que
vous avez
mené madame la Présidente au côté de la
députée Émilie chandlerur on est passé
d'une proposition de loi je m'y arrête
un quart de
seconde qui tendait à
créer des tribunaux spécialisés
à avec un travail qui était qui n'était
pas achevé qui n'était pas abouti les
magistrats étaient totalement hostiles à
cette création en revanche ils ont
parfaitement accueilli les pôles
[Musique]
spécialisé si on peut résumer ce que
sont ces pôles spécialisé bonjour
monsieur le sénateur c'est en réalité
l'idée que on ne peut plus et qu'on ne
peut pas fonctionner en silo et que tout
le monde doit se
parler force de sécurité intérieure
évidemment mais aussi parquet juge
d'application des peines juge aux
affaires familiales et cetera et cetera
c'est l'antiérignac si je je je puis euh
me permettre de de résumer les choses
j'ai souhaité m'inspirer de vos
recommandations pour consacrer
l'articulation indispensable entre
procédure civile et procédure pénal ça
aussi c'était deux silos
distincts qui fonctionnit en parallèle
et qui mérite grâce à une organisation
dédiée est spécialisé de de se parler et
d'échanger on évite à l'évidence des
situations qui sont dramatique et
irréversible en fait ces pô spécialisé
constituent un message très fort envoyé
à toutes les victimes euh qui mérite
bien sûr un accompagnement spécifique et
un jugement adapté à la complexité de
ces violence vous avez souligné madame
la Présidente l'importance de la
formation de T les acteurs
judiciaires et l'exemple que vous nous
avez donné illustre à quel point
euh il y a encore dans les esprits des
choses qui mériteraient d'être balayé si
j'ose dire d'un d'un vrai revers de
manche pour ne pas dire d'un d'un grand
coup de balai mais
mais retenir que il y a aussi beaucoup
de bonne
volonté que naturellement les formations
des enquêteurs des magistrats des
greffiers des avocats également et de
tous les partenaires je pense aux
associations je pense aux soignants je
pense aux services sociaux tout cela est
absolument indispensable et je partage
totalement votre préoccupation que j'ai
souhaité d'ailleurs consacrer dans une
circulaire que j'ai signé en novembre le
24 novembre
2023 ainsi les membres des pôles
spécialisés participeront à des actions
de formation local organisé au plus
proche et au plus près des acteurs de
terrain ce qui intègre évidemment toutes
les évolutions récentes normatives et
les nouveaux outils de protection les
magistrats vont pouvoir s'appuyer sur
des moyens numériques dédiés avec
l'applicatif sispop système informatisé
de suivi de politique pénale
prioritaire autorisé par décret du 10
octobre 2023 cet outil indispensable
central l'ensemble des données relatives
aux situations familiales issu à la fois
des procédures civiles mais aussi des
procédures pénales et les informations
échangées dans le cadre des comités de
pilotage il est doté de fonctionnalité
de pilotage des mesures de protection de
mécanismes d'alerte automatisé et
personnalisable de radars en matière de
protection de l'enfance ou
lors de la sortie de détention qui était
une préoccupation très très forte
évidemment des
victimes qui ne peuvent pas vivre dans
la crainte tout simplement
exprimé vous l'avez relevé madame la
Présidente l'intervention judiciaire en
matière de vif est très dépendante de la
réactivité de ses partenaires et ça
implique évidemment une coordination
interministérielle à tous les
niveaux bien sûr une coordination niveau
politique c'est bien le sens du plan
gouvernemental renouvelé le 8 mars
dernier désormais piloté par ma collègue
Aurore berger dont la détermination je
le crois est connue de toutes et de
tous quatre axes majeurs lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes égalité
professionnel économique santé des
femmes et la culture de l'égalité qui
engage évidemment toutes nos
administrations sans exception alors
j'entends votre inquiétude sur la
réalité de cette coordination et je veux
vous assurer que nous avons engagé une
profonde
révolution je vous le dis sans
coordination effective nous ne serions
jamais parvenus à déployer 5500 TGD en
2023 contre seulement je vous demande de
retenir ce chiffre 9 76 en 2020
l'évolution elle est extrêmement
importante plus
de plus de 1000 barres en seulement 2
ans 145 unités d'accueil pédiatrique
enfants sans danger pour protéger les
enfants
covictimes nous avions envisagé un nuapè
par département nous souhaitons
désormais un nuaped par ressort
judiciaire dont il est vrai que
c'est un outil
absolument
performant dont plus personne ne
pourrait songer
à à se
passer nous ne serions jamais parvenu à
absorber une augmentation de plus de 123
% du nombre de condamnations des auteurs
impliquant une prise en charge
disciplinaire s'il y avait pas cette
mobilisation totale alors de nombreuses
tion conjointe engageant plusieurs
ministères ont vu le jour et sont a
autant d'illustration de cette
coordination circulaire interministériel
du 25 novembre 2021 ayant permis les
dépôts de plaintes et le recueil de
preuvees au sein des établissements de
santé bon l'utilité je je veux pas m'y
arrêter tout le monde imagine que c'est
extrêmement douloureux de devoir répéter
les choses et cetera en réalité c'est
les enquêteurs c'est la justice c'est la
médecine médecine
légale qui vient vers la victime et pas
l'inverse et c'est une
évolution
majeure dans les pratiques qui sont les
nôtres dans le prolongement j'ai signé
en mai
2023 la convention permettant le
déploiement national d'un lieu de prise
en charge globale des victimes à
l'INSTAT du dispositif maison des femes
au côté des ministres de l'intérieur et
du ministre de la
Santé circulaire d'avril 2 22 conjointe
là encore signé avec le ministère de la
Santé permettant le déploiement du
protocole féminicide consacré à la prise
en charge immédiate des enfants présents
euh pendant le pendant le
drame témoin de ces violences et cet
enfant témoin est est devenu un enfant
victime euh je me souviens de ce que dit
euh serulnique qui dit qu'un enfant qui
assiste à des
violences subit un traumatisme digne de
d'une scène de guerre en réalité son
psychisme est évidemment totalement
déchiré par ce qu'il par ce dont il a
été le témoin chaque avancée dans le
champ judiciaire est est
systématiquement intégrée dans une
action coordonnée avec mes autres
collègues du gouvernement et ma priorité
je je veux le redire
ici absolue est une bonne application
des lois par le ministère de la Justice
évidemment et par l'ensemble des
services de l'État cette articulation
inter ministérielle est en outre
garantie au sein du ministère de la
Justice grâce à un pilotage interne que
j'ai confié à la haute fonctionnaire à
l'égalité des droits dont la Cour des
comptes à saluer le positionnement à
haut
niveau pas tous les jours qu'on reçoit
des compliments de la Cour des comptes
et donc quand on reçoit des compliments
de la Cour des comptes il faut savoir
les apprécier à leur juste très juste
valeur un mot madame la Présidente si
vous me le permettez sur la lutte contre
les violences sexuelles et
sexistes depuis 2017 la France est
pleinement engagé politiquement comme
juridiquement dans la mise en œuvre
concrète d'une législation sévère et
efficace pour réprimer toutes les formes
de violence sexuelle avec la
détermination et la rigueur
nécessaire vous avez voté des avancées
législatives qui à mes yeux sont
déterminantes qui conforent la place de
la France pour faire avancer les droits
des victimes de violence sexuelle je
pense en particulier à la loi du 3 août
2018 qui a renforcé la répression du
cyber
euh
du cyber harcèlement et créé les
infractions d'outrage sexiste ainsi que
le délit de voyurisme je pense aussi à
la loi du 21 avril
2021 porté par madame la sénatrice
billon qui renforce la protection des
mineurs victimes sans renverser la
charge de la preuve en fixant un âge en
dein duquel un mineur ne peut consentir
un acte
sexuel je prendre ici un instant pour
éclairer les controverses qui conduisent
de manière à mon sens injustifiée à
conclure à l'inaction de notre
justice depuis
2017 le nombre d'affaires nouvelles de
viol portait la connaissance des
procureurs de la République est en
constante
augmentation
ainsi
personnes été mise en cause dans des
affaires de viol orienté par les
parquets en 2022
contre
affaire personne mise en cause
pardonnez-moi en 2017 c'est précisément
une augmentation de 104
%. lorsque les faits sont
caractérisés et l'auteur identifié la
réponse pénale est je le dis syst
j'ai donné dès février 2021 instruction
au procureur de poursuivre l'enquête y
compris mesdames monsieur le sénateur
lorsque les faits apparaissent prescrits
ce qui
permet de
découvrir d'autres
victimes le nombre de condamnations de
majeur pour viol a augmenté de 30 %
depuis
passant de 960 en 2017 à
120060 en
2022 le nombre de condamnations de
majeur pour agression sexuelle était de
5617 en
2017 il est de
7 400 85 en
2022 et la progression est encore plus
importante s'agissant des condamnations
pour viol incestueux commis sur un
mineur c'est une progression de 129 %
entre 2017 et 2021 passant de 177 à
405 les condamnations pour agression
sexuelle incestueuse ou atteinte
sexuelle incestueuse ont progressé quant
à elle de 91 % passant de
675 à
1290 un dernier chiffre sur le quantum
des peines prononcé en matière de viol
il est de 11 ans en
moyenne et c'est un des quantum les plus
importants les plus élevés
d'Europe enfin je veux indiquer qu'il
est impossible en l'état de nos données
d'établir un pourcentage de classement
comparer le nombre de plaintes et de
condamnation est illusoire car ce ne
sont pas les mêmes procédures qui sont
comptabilisées et ce seraiit nié les
exigences probatoires fondamentales dans
notre État de droit permettant de
poursuivre et de condamner évidemment
les auteurs on peut pas conclure à
l'inaction de la justice ni à son
impunité les chiffres en sont me
semble-t-il les pousstouflantes
démonstration et je veux mettre en garde
tous ceux
qui publiquement tiennent ce discours
mais au-delà de la critique on est
habitué à être critiqué mais ce qui me
chagrine le plus c'est que c'est
susceptible de décourager bon nombre de
victimes qui se finalement qu'on laisse
dans une espèce d'aquabonisme ah ben ça
sert à rien parce que la justice ne
condamne pas parce que la justice
n'enquête pas parce que la justice et C
je vous ai donné un certain nombre de
chiffres je souhaite vraiment mettre un
terme à à ces choses qui sont dites et
qui ont surtout comme effet délétaire et
dévastateur le fait de
démobiliser des victimes qui
souhaiteraient déposer plainte et qui se
disent à quoi bon ce discours est un
discours absolument contreproductif
entendre la longueur de plateau de télé
porter plainte ça sert à rien que la
justice fait rien euh qu'elle est
l'xiste voilà c'est absolument
insupportable ce n'est pas conforme à la
réalité et moi je veux dire aux victimes
portez plainte et saisissez la justice
évidemment tout n'est pas
parfait mais nous faisons tout et
j'allais dire tous ensemble pour que les
choses bougent et qu'elles aillent dans
le bon sens on doit poursuivre les
efforts pour accueillir la parole des
victimes pour la respecter l'accueillir
et la respecter et pour moi les choses
vont évidemment de de paire du dépôt de
la plainte à l'issue de la procédure
pénale et il faut évidemment redonner
aux victimes confiance dans
l'institution
judicire on a des résultats avec la mise
en place des cours criminelles
départementales partie des questions que
légitimement madame la Présidente vous
me posez dont la généralisation je
rappelle est effective depuis janvier
2023 on sait déjà
que les crimes sexuels qui constituent
90 % des affaires renvoyé devant les
Cours criminelles sont jugé plus vite et
permettent de faire baisser les
correctionnalisations
correctionnalisation pour une victime
c'est insupportable euh elle sait ce
qu'elle a vécu elle a vécu un viol c'est
comme ça que ces faits méritent d'être
qualifié et on dit à un moment à la
victime mais vous allez être jugé devant
le tribunal correctionnel c'est quelque
chose que les victimes ne supportent pas
et euh on peut
entendre leur désarroi leur
désappointement je crois d'ailleurs que
les mots ne sont pas justes la moyenne
du délai d'audiencement mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur des
dossiers d'accusé détenu est en effet de
5 de 6 pardonnez-moi vir5 mois et de 8,7
mois pour les accusés libres ce qui est
particulièrement bref au regard en
particulier
des 18 mois en moyenne du délai
d'audiencement aux assises si j'ose dire
classique sur les h premiers cours les h
premières courses expérimentales
euh on a remarqué une augmentation des
décisions criminelles rendu de plus de
50 % et c'est un chiffre énorme et je
précise que le taux d'acquitement est le
même que pour les cours d'assise environ
5 % c'estd que sur le terrain un
probatoire euh nous sommes à égalité
entre euh euh ces deux
juridictions évidemment on n' pas achev
notre mission pour mieux protéger les
victimes en amont et en aval de
l'intervention de la
justice et depuis 3 ans euh j'ai porté
une augmentation des moyens consacrés à
l'aide aux victimes euh au profit de nos
associations
partenairire vous avez ainsi voté un
budget alloué à l'aide aux victimes de
47 millions en
2024 contre 26 millions en 2017 c'est
une augmentation de 80 %. alors faut-il
changer à nouveau la loi pénale au
regard des débats actuels sur la
définition du viol les débats récents
parfois virulents imposent de livrer une
lecture honnête et rigoureuse sur notre
législation d'abord la législation
française en matière de viol et sans
doute la plus répressive
d'Europe 15 ans de réclusion criminelle
jusqu'à la
perpétuité avec un certain nombre de
circonstances aggravantes lorsque
l'Espagne qui est toujours une référence
fixe une peine de 6 à 12 ans depuis
2022 notre définition du viol protège
les victimes et permet de sanctionner
lourdement les auteurs s'attachant à
démontrer la responsabilité de
l'agresseur qui impose une relation
sexuelle non consentie le juge est
évidemment le garant de la liberté notre
droit permet de condamner lourdement en
appréciant concrètement l'absence de
consentement des victimes la preuve est
rapportée par l'accusation et par
personne d'autre est-ce le rôle de la
loi pénale que de définir le
consentement d'une victime au lieu de
s'attacher à définir la responsabilité
du criminel voilà comment les choses
méritent d'être dites et les questions
méritent d'être posées avec des risques
de glissement vers une
contractualisation des relation sexuelle
dont je le crois personne ne veut et je
veux ici mettre en garde quant au risque
de braquer la
focale sur la victime alors que le seul
responsable c'est le violeur le risque
majeur est de faire peser la preuve du
consentement sur la
victime aussi moi j'appelle à plus
grande prudence ce que veulent les
victimes et nous devons y répondre c'est
des procédures plus
rapides des procédures
compréhensibles une meilleure
information à tous les stades de la
procédure mais également une information
pour le grand public qui peut désormais
appréhender la complexité de ses
affaires grâce à une loi que vous avez
porté qui permet de filmer les audiences
qui permet certain nombre de nos
compatriotes de bien comprendre
ce que sont les mécanismes judiciaires
et la difficulté de rendre la justice
c'est toujours mieux que le prisme de la
fait diversification qu'on nous offre en
35 secondes sur certaines chaînes pour
dire que la justice ne fonctionne pas en
général d'ailleurs sont pas des juristes
qui font les commentaires peu importe je
ferme la parenthèse il est intéressant
de savoir que le fait de que la justice
se donne à voir per de mieux
l'appréhender de mieux la comprendre et
de la critiquer d'une façon qui n'est
pas une façon
niéliste prise en charge globale des
auteurs car les violences faites aux
femmes qu'elles soit intime ou sur la
voie publique appellent des réponses
spécifique
intégrant des démarches de
soin je voudrais vous convaincre de ma
totale détermination à combler toutes
les failles ou lacunes relevant tant des
pratiques professionnelles que de la
loi encore une
fois chaque
infraction chaque viol chaque
féminicide est un échec pour toute notre
notre
société mais chaque
plainte transmise au
parquet est en soit un progrès et si la
justice n'est pas saisie je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est une évidence mais
parfois il faut redire les évidences si
la justice n'est pas sdie naturellement
elle ne peut pas
intervenir alors la justice n'a pas
d'appriori dans notre pays souvent
lorsque les procédures sont classées bah
disons-le c'est faute de preuve pas
comment faut d'identification de
l'auteur tout cela c'est une constante
c'est tout un système probatoire c'est
c'est l'état de droit c'est le
fonctionnement judiciaire tel que
tel qu'il doit être consacré ça ne veut
pas dire que les faits n'ont pas eu lieu
mais simplement qu'ils n'ont pas pu être
démontré en justice et il nous faut
inciter les victimes à déposer plainte
le plus vite possible pour cela édquons
nos enfants et tous les
adultes à identifier toutes les
situations de violence sexuelle car nous
disposons je pense d'un
arsenal législatif pour y répondre alors
s'agissant de la position de la France
sur la directive
européenne en
réalité il s'agit d'un débat de
compétence alors je sais que certains
ont instrumentalisé ce
débat pour dire que la France ne voulait
pas que la France n'avait pas envie que
la France était
rétrograde
c'est d'abord c'est surtout et c'est à
nos yeux uniquement un débat de
compétence c'est un débat
de compétence de l'Union et un débat de
doctrine et on va le dire très
clairement les
juristes ne sont pas d'accord entre eux
il est tout à fait clair qu'à ce stade
des
négociations il est
primordial de ne prendre aucun risque
sur un texte qui pourrait être annulé
par la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne et plutôt que d'avoir avancé
encore que je le dis notre législation
est la plus répressive d'Europe les
femmes alors
auraient beaucoup perdu parce que si le
texte devait être
censuré et
bien ceux qui je le redis parfois des
fins politicienne instrumentalise ce
débat serait euh les responsables d'un
recul absolumente historique que moi je
n'envisage pas une
seconde de de supporter nous avons une
législation nous sommes très clairs dans
notre
législation prendre des risques et
encourir la censure de la Cour de
justice de
l'Union c'est un risque que moi je ne
veux pas prendre les femmes ont besoin
de sécurité juridique le texte européen
comporte des avancées
majeures qu'il ne faut pas
fragiliser
j'aimerais à
présent évoquer un chantier historique
qui est celui de l'inscription de l'IVG
dans notre
Constitution
j'aurai l'honneur de me présenter devant
vous
prochainement avec ce projet de loi
constitutionnelle relatif à la liberté
de recourir à
l'interruption à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse adopté il y a
quelques jours par l'Assemblée
national à une majorité c'est un petit
clin d'œuil badin que je vous adresse
non pas des 3/5e mais des
9/10e ce projet il est à l'évidence un
point d'équilibre entre les nombreux
travaux qui ont été engagés dans les
deux chambres et le
Sénat a été c'est bien
normal plus que respectecé dans la
préparation de cette version de
compromis comment puis-je le dire
simplement l'écriture proposée par le
gouvernement est à 95 % celle du
Sénat je dis 95 pour faire chiffre
rond pour dire
98,5 donc on a entendu le scénat
évidemment on a de textes qui sont
différents on a cherché le point
d'équilibre le point de
compromis je pense que
l'enjeu
ne permettent aucune instrumentalisation
politicienne et je
n'envisage en aucune
façon
que de Tell choses puissent traverser
les
esprits le projet de loi il comporte une
disposition unique qui a pour objet de
modifier l'article 34 de la Constitution
en y ajoutant après le 17e alinéa un
alinéa ainsi rédigé la loi
détermine les conditions dans lesquelles
s'exerce la liberté garantie à la femme
d'avoir recours à une interruption
volontaire de
grossesse je veux rassurer toutes celles
et tous ceux qui craignent que ce projet
ne consacre un droit absolu et sans
limite non ça n'est évidemment pas ce
que nous
voulons non ce n'est pas ce que fait le
texte le terme
garanti seule concession faite à
l'Assemblée
nationale seule quand je disais tout à
l'heure 95 % peut augmenter encore le
chiffre n'emporte pas la création d'un
droit opposable absolu sans limite et ça
n'est pas moi mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur sénateur qui le dit c'est le
Conseil d'État
dans un avis dont je vous recommande à
toutes euh à vous monsieur le sénateur
la
lecture parce qu'il est particulièrement
étayé il précise que j'ouvre les
guillemets à cet instant par elle-même
l'inscription de la liberté de recourir
à une IVG dans la Constitution dans les
termes que propose le gouvernement ne
remet pas en cause les autres droits et
libertés que la Constitution garantit
tel que notamment la liberté de
conscience qui soutend la liberté des
médecins et sages femmes de ne pas
pratiquer une IVG ainsi que la liberté
d'expression et par ailleurs je veux que
la liberté de recourir à
l'IVG je constate que cette liberté n'a
pas été
consacré au niveau
constitutionnel contrairement d'ailleurs
à ce que l'on pourrait penser d'emblé il
y a toute une analyse du Conseil d'État
qui rappelle que tant sur le plan
national que que supranational
Convention euréenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme jurisprudence de la
Cour européenne jurisprudence de la Cour
de justice la loi veille n'est pas
constitutionnellement protégé voilà
cette analyse encore une fois elle n'est
pas mienne elle n'est pas partisane elle
est le fruit d'une
réflexion portée par le Conseil d'État
et exprimée en des termes qui sont des
termes je les ai qualifiés comme tel et
je le refais en des termes
lumineux
alors le Conseil
d'État nous rappelle qu'en revanche le
principe de sauvegarde de la dignité de
la personne humaine a été
consacré comme principe à valeur
constitutionnelle par une décision du
Conseil constitutionnel de
1994 et qu'il en va de même du principe
de liberté de conscience des médecins
consacré comme principe fondamental
reconnu par les lois de la République
par une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel de
2001 dignité de la personne consacrée au
plus haut niveau liberté de conscience
consacré au plus haut niveau et
liberté une garantie à la femme
d'avorter ne serait pas protégé de la
même façon comprenez bien que dans le
triptique
là il nous manque un élément et cet
élément c'est la protection
constitutionnelle que je souhaiterais
que
nous puissions tous ensemble de façon
transpartisane mettre en œuvre et mettre
en place et pour dire les choses
clairement la sauvegarde de la dignité
humaine la liberté de conscience des
médecins ont déjà valeurs
constitutionnelles voilà et la liberté
d'avoir recours à l'IVG
non
bon cette seule question est est est la
réponse à cette seule question devrait
me semble-t-il nous inciter à adopter le
texte alors j'entends évidemment les
craintes quant à notre Constitution qui
deviendrait selon une formule désormais
est consacré un catalogue sans cohérence
des droits sociaux et
sociétaux bon très clairement
euh sur ces
sujets
sociétaux
philosophiqu je respecte évidemment
l'opinion de toutes et de tous pas
contraindre les
consciences je pense que nous le savons
la liberté de penser c'est quelque chose
qui est important pour
autant
la
Constitution pardon de le dire ainsi
dispose déjà de
nombreux droits et libertés et c'est
même une de ses fonctions majeures
réunir l'ensemble des droits et
libertés particulièrement
important la seule question qui vous
sera posée le 28 février prochain c'est
la liberté de recourir à l'IVG
recouvret-elle à vos yeux une importance
suffisante pour être protégé par notre
constitu
voilà comment à ce
stade je me permets de poser la la
question et c'est à vous en tant que
constituant qu'il appartiendra bien sûr
de de répondre et vous l'aurez compris
en ce qui me concerne la réponse c'est
oui et à ceux qui répondent que l'IVG
n'est pas menacé en
France je dis que on nécrit pas la
Constitution pour le présent on l'écrit
d'abord et surtout pour l'avenir et
c'est le propre même de notre loi
suprême
elle a pour vocation à
duré la provocation de de valoir pour
l'avenir en protégeant évidemment nos
droits mais en regardant
vers un horizon qui peut-être un horizon
éloigné et les expérience
étrangère en la matière nous démontre
que rien n'est
acquis
par revenir sur ce qui s'est passé outre
atlantique pas revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé en Europe où l'on a contraint des
femmes à entendre les battements de cœur
de du ftus qu'ell portait pour les
dissuader d'avorter à mes yeux une
torture
insupportable alors vous m'avez posé une
question précise madame la Présidente
s'agissant du calendrier alors j'ai
précisé lors du vote de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a quelques jours que nous
prend le temps et qu'il faut aller au
bout de cette révision alors je sais les
mois qui a pu provoquer l'évocation
d'une date de congrès avant même que les
chambres ne se soient prononcé
oui mais je je je je avant de dire que
c'est pas malin ce que je voudrais je
voudrais vous dire deux mots là-dessus
sur l'expression non non mais sur sur
sur les choses qui ont été dites et en
particulier sur les choses qui ont été
dites par le Président de la
République ces choses elles ont été
dites monsieur le sénateur lors des
rencontres de Saint-Denis et le
président de la République dit
précisément
ceci un examen dans chaque assemblée
pourra avoir
lieu au 1er trimestre 2024
afin qu'un congrès puisse être
envisagé le 4 mars
alors le 4 mars prochain mais pardon
vous dites c'est pas malin et moi je dis
et moi je dis c'est à la fois
respectueux et prudent bon voilà mais
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que
franchement alors
voyez une perception des choses
naturellement pour le coup
différente et et partisane mais est-ce
que ça
mérite que cette
réforme ne soit pas envisagé pour des
questions de c'est pas
malin moi je dis c'est c'était très
prudent je je je je vous ai relu
exactement ce que le président de la
République a exprimé est-ce que sur une
réforme aussi importante que celle-là
sur une liberté aussi importante que
celle-là pour toutes les femmes de notre
pays le fait que nous soyons
si alors je je je vais y mettre je vais
abandonner le le le mode indicatif
monsieur le sénateur pour ne pas vous
froisser utiliser tous les conditionnels
qui vont bien tous les si toutes les
virgules tous les trois points de
suspension ok mais franchement de quoi
parle-t-on on parle d'une liberté
fondamentale pour les femmes et puis et
puis nous serions le le premier pays à
inscrire cela dans notre Constitution
bon après chacun sera avec sa
conscience moi je ne veux pas violer les
consciences je n'en ai pas les moyens je
suis parfaitement
respectueux du travail
parlementaire je peux rien vous dire
d'autre mesurons les
enjeux nous avons des choses d'ors et
déjà garanties par notre Constitution
sauf l'essentiel qui est la liberté de
la femme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure dans
dans ce dans ce triptique que je regarde
avec beaucoup d'objectivité c'est un
travail de de de d'analyse auquel
d'ailleurs a procédé le Conseil d'État
je trouve assez désolant que euh nous ne
consacrons pas mais j'ai la conviction
que au-delà des susceptibilités
euh qui peuvent s'exprimer au fond euh
et heureusement qu'elles s'exprime
nous irons vers l'essentiel et
l'essentiel c'est de garantir aux femmes
une liberté qui est celle de disposer de
leur corps pas plus compliqué que ça
B donc moi je veux vous rassurer madame
la Présidente mais je pense que vous
n'êtes pas
inquiète on prendra le temps qu'il
faudra pour aller au bout de cette
révision parce que je pense profondément
qu'elle est indispensable
voilà je veux redire ici que nous avons
tout fait mais vraiment tout fait pour
que l'écriture proposée dans ce projet
de révision soit accepté par une
majorité de sénateurs parce que ce
projet c'est pas une initiative du
gouvernement seul vous le savez il
arrive après de nombreuses initiatives
parlementaires neuf initiatives
parlementaires je crois bon
euh nous nous sommes dans une forme
nous non non
mais et je dis le contraire d'ailleurs
on partle d'initiative parlementairire
nous nous avions dit dans dans un
premier temps le président de la
République avait dit nous regardons les
initiatives parlementaires et puis nous
nous nous ferons quelque chose de cela
bon au fond mais je ne veux heurter
aucune sensibilité c'est une forme de 3è
lecture et le gouvernement a pris je
l'ai déjà dit la quasi intégralité de
l'écriture du Sénat alors moi je dis
tout simplement faut pas rater ce moment
il faut pas rater cette alignement des
planètes et pour conclure je je je veux
saluer madame la Présidente je pense
avoir été complet sur cette question je
veux saluer les les les travaux en cours
qui sont menés par votre délégation
relativement aux familles
monoparentales réalité sociale elle
touche très majoritairement les femmes
et elles accentuent évidemment leur
précarisation et tout cela doit être
pris en compte dans le traitement
judiciaire alors vous m'interrogez sur
les disparités
jurisprudentielles ainsi que sur le
faible montant de la pension alimentaire
fixé judiciaairement bon le juge aux
affaires familiales il se fonde sur des
critères qui ont été fixés par la
loi pardonnez-moi par la loi notamment
c'est l'article
371- 2 de notre Code civil pour
déterminer le montant de la contribution
à l'entretien et l'éducation des
enfants ressources du parent débiteur et
du parent créancier charge du parent
débiteur du parent créancier besoin de
l'enfant et afin d'accompagner le juge
dans la fixation du montant de cette
contribution un référentiel indicatif
fait l'objet d'une diffusion publique
accessible au justiciable c'est un
simulateur qui est accessible sur notre
site Internet ainsi que
sur toute nouvelle application
justice.fr que je vous recommande de
télécharger et au total ce sont plus de
1000 personnes par jour qui utilise ce
simulateur
c'est une petite fierté que de l'avoir
mise en place il y a des femmes qui
aujourd'hui on le
sait ne peuvent pas ne veulent pas
n'osent pas quitter un conjoint avec
lequel ell vivent
des jours bien tristes parce qu'ell se
disent mais comment je vais faire pour
élever le gamin et cet outil permet aux
femmes d'avoir une simulation immédiate
de ce à quoi elle pourrait prétendre en
terme de pension alimentaire alors ça ne
règle pas la question du rééquilibrage
je dois dire mais vous le savez toutes
et tous
que le Gard des saau ne peut pas donner
de directec
peut pas le faire auprès d'un procureur
moins encore auprès d'un juge du siège
mais on peut en revanche attirer
l'attention et c'est aussi notre rôle
aujourd'hui sur les disparités il y a
aucune raison effectivement que les
femmes
soient les victimes au fond d'une
jurisprudence qui ne prendrait pas en
considération la réalité des éléments
pécuniers
que vous nous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure aucune
raison je veux quand même parler une
toute petite seconde et puis ensuite je
réponds pardon il quelques questions
j'imagine je TR très vite il me reste
quelques mots je quand même rappeler
l'intermédiation des pensions
alimentaires qui est quand même quelque
chose qui a été fait en en faveur des
femmes qui leur vie j'ai j'ai rencontré
moi-même en différents déplacements que
j'ai pu faire à la caave notamment des
femmes qui mais avait affaire
à des pères qui parfois avaient oublié
les obligations qui sont les leurs
l'intermédiation pension alimentaire
c'est quand même un un un progrès permet
vous le savez de de sécuriser chaque
mois le versement de la pension
alimentaire en prévenant le risque
d'impayer en 2022 je donne ce chiffre
j'ai pratiquement terminé 200 millions
d'euros ont été recouvrés par l'ARIPA la
précarisation des femmes qui
représentent 82 % des familles
monoparentales c'est un enjeu majeur
pour notre
société et ça nécessite une réponse
globale pour les soutenir je suivrai
ainsi avec la plus grande attention vos
travaux vos
recommandations
pour assurer une parfaite diffusion au
sein de l'institution judiciaire ce qui
sera sans aucun doute l'occasion de
redire vos préoccupations quant au
déséquilibre jurisprudentiel qui peut
être parfois pour la fixation des
pensions alimentaires voilà madame la
Présidente Mesdames les sénatrice
monsieur sénateur je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre à toutes les
questions des membres de votre
délégation merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre pour ce point très exhaustif je
sais que mes collègues brûlent de vous
poser des questions donc je vous poserai
les miennes qu' qu'après euh je donne la
parole tout d'abord à Annique billon
suivrons ensuite Laurence Rossignol puis
Joseline
Antoine merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le garde des saau pour cette
audition devant notre délégation au
droits des femmes ça me donne l'occasion
de de vous remercier pour à la fois
l'engagement que vous avez pris depuis
la prise de fonction en tant que garde
des saut pour la lutte contre les
violences intrafamiliales et finalement
ça fait écho à à la discussion général
hier de notre président Hervé Marseille
don le travail de cononstruction la loi
que j'ai porté en 2021 effectivement
elleelle elle a été construite grâce à
ce travail que nous avons eu ensemble et
je vous en remercie sur d'abord sur sur
l'IVG bien entendu et comme depuis
toutes ces discussions que nous avons pu
avoir au sein de la délégation et dans
l'hémicycle sur la
constitutionnalisation je voterai
favorablement en faveur de la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
oui il y a peut-être eu une maladresse
de calendrier nous avons eu l'occasion
d'en débattre déjà longuement donc je
pense que le débat a été déjà assez
riche et et je je reste attaché à
forcément à ce droit fondamental pour
moi c'est un droit fondamental pour les
générations à venir et je suis heureuse
d'entendre ce matin votre détermination
peut-être revenir d'abord sur les
ordonnances de protection puisque en
novembre 2023 beréranger Couillard
annonçait qu'elles allaient passer à 24h
et la requérante d'une ordonnance de
protection doit apporter la preuve de la
vraisemblance des violences et de
l'actualité du danger ce sont ces
preuves qui doivent caractériser de
manière indupitable l'existence de
violence et donc de danger et et là
c'est pas toujours le cas ces critères
posent des des enfin on a du mal à
appréhender ces critères et donc parfois
le véritable danger et quelque chose une
notion un petit peu floue et or les les
victimes sont en fait déjà en
danger de mort
parfois l'examen de la proposition loi
d'Émilie Chandler suite au rapport
rougeevf porté avec notre présidente a
démontré l'utilité de raccourcir ses
délais donc moi j'ai quelques questions
qu'en est-il de l'efficacité de
l'ordonnance de protection combien de
victimes en bénéfici et comptez-vous
revoir les critères de l'ordonnance de
protection vous avez évoqué la médecine
légale on sait qu'elle joue un rôle
considérable dans l'accompagnement des
victimes mais aussi pour détecter les
victimes et pour les enques quur euh je
vais parler de l'avend en 2021
l'équivalent temps plein c'était 0,8
équivalent temps plein il y avait 1200
actes de réaliser quand il y en aurait
pu en avoir 3000 pour le cas des
violences intrafamiliales donc ID de la
situation dans les autres départements
et avez-vous imaginé revoir ce ce ces
équivalent temp plein leur nombre pour
avoir une vraie médecine légale dans les
départements la lutte contre les
violence faite aux femmes depuis 2017 et
l'annonce du président de la République
a pris une tournure importante dans dans
notre travail à la fois législatif et
dans la société la libération de la
parole des enfants a pris elle un tour
important au moment de la création de la
civise et la civise a permis de libérer
cette parole des victimes mineures le
départ forcé du
co-président Édouard le juge Édouard
Durand à a créé beaucoup d'émois
beaucoup de d'inquiétude par rapport à à
cette à cette
formidable je dirais à cet engouement et
cette libération de la parole des
victimes donc je le rappelle 160000 VI
victimes mineures tous les ans alors
qu'avez-vous imaginé pour lutter
efficacement contre les agressions sur
mineur tout le monde savait mais en
général c'est tellement inconcevable que
personne le révèle comment et avec quel
outil mieux prendre en compte la parole
des enfants et il y a un sujet qui
revient régulièrement c'est
l'imprescriptibilité alors que nous
avions voté des disposition finalement
avec la prescriptibilité glissante
est-ce que c'est un sujet sur lesquel
vous vous réfléchissez ou vous vous
n'avez pas bougé de position euh
peut-être pour finir puisque je sais que
le temps est est compté madame la
Présidente euh les femmes dans un petit
sujet plus léger on va dire femmes dans
les les professions judiciaires puisque
nous avons porté avec ma ma collègue et
présidente Dominique Verrien une
proposition de loi sur la place des
femmes dans dans les dans la haute
fonction publique et donc cette place
des femmes dans les postes à
responsabilité alors les femmes sont de
plus en plus nombreuses dans les
professions judiciaires donc en 2016 une
étude demandé par le Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature constatait que la
position de chef de juridiction montre
une forte masculinisation tout à fait
atypique eu égard à la féminisation du
corps au 1er janvier 2023 71 % des juges
en France sont des femmes donc la
magistrature est aujourd'hui une
profession non mixte finalement mais
pour autant les postes de responsabilité
eux sont essentiellement occupé par des
hommes donc ben quelle solution quelle
qu'est-ce que vous vous avez imaginé
pour que les femmes occupent plus de
responsabilité aussi dans la profession
dans les professions judiciaires je vous
remercie j'ai fait aussi vite merciè je
P FEM de justice vous remercie je passe
la parole à Laurence
Rossignol merci madame la Présidente une
question une remarque et une précision
historique et je commencerai d'abord par
dire que je j'adère au propos du garde
des saut les choses avancent voilà c'est
incontestable elles avancent dans la
justice euh je peux vous signer si vous
voulez euh non non c'est vrai je je vois
que vos collaborateurs souris euh bonne
journée bonne journée
euh S c'est pas une bonne journée c'est
une bonne semaine ouis non non mais
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
incontestable et euh je je partage bon
nombre des des remarques des discussions
qui restent encore en cours et je les
questions de de définition du viol sont
piégeuses parce que je ne crois pas
qu'aucune définition nous met à l'abri
d'un débat sur le consentement dans les
cours voilà c'est ni celle d'aujourd'hui
ni celle ni une autre et que par
ailleurs je pense aussi qu'on notre
définition est bien on pourrait
peut-être y ajouter une définition de ce
qu'est le viol qui dirait le viol est
une relation sexuelle non consentie
voilà ça ça nuirait pas ça ne nuirait
pas et ça
conserverait l'article tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui ceci étant posé ma question
va être plus précise et plus technique
je crois les cours criminel
départemental ont effectivement des des
résultat c'est vrai pour autant je me
demande si c'est la
meilleure instance pour toutes les
affaires je pense en particulier vous
savez que la délégation Dr des femmes du
Sénat est très soucieuse des suites des
affaires sur la pornographie le Pr fren
le procès French Bouake va arriver
probablement 2025 me dit-on maintenant
et à cet instant il est renvoyé devant
une cour criminelle départementale je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit le bon endroit
voilà mais c'est le seul possible dans
la voie aujourd'hui j'y viens monsieur
Gard des saau seriez-vous d'accord à
pour soutenir une proposition noit qui
en fait étendrait les cours d'assis
spécialisé aux affaires de traite des
êtres humains en bande organisé
puisqueaujourd'hui les cours d'assise
spécialisé
sont pour les affaires de terrorisme et
pour les affaires de trafic de
stupéfiants en bande organisé est-ce que
le trafic la traite des êtres humains en
bande organisée pourrait être une de
compétence des cours d'assis spécialisé
et peut-être aussi des viols criels je
me suis m'étais fait la remarque au
moment où il y a eu le procès dans le
Vaucluse de cet homme où il y avait 51
prévenus si ma mémoire est bonne d'un
viol cériel celui qui s'est daté sa
femme
et peut-être ça aurait mérité et sur les
affaires de de de traite des êtres
humains et les affaires
pardon non
Avignon ENIT le le les faits étaient
dans le
vlus celui qui drogait sa femme la fais
violer par G voilà c'est celui bref peu
peu importe et donc je je je me disais
que sur les affaires French bouakeé puis
après on en aura d'autres autres
affaires concernant les viols dans
l'industrie pornographique un deuxième
procès qui vient derrière peut-être la
cour d'assise spécialement composé
serait la bonne voilà je vous demande
pas de répondre à cette question là à
cet instant parce qu'elle demande
effectivement d'être expertisé et de
travailler sur l'IVG la
constionalisation de l'IVG je c'est plus
à mes collègues que je m'adresse qu'à
vous monsieur gardessau en fait si
jamais le Sénat se mettait en tête
de ralentir le garde a dit que on y
consacrera le temps qu'il faudra mais
d'adopter des amendement qui
fragiliseraiit la possibilité d'adoption
à l'Assemblée nationale je voudrais
prévenir d'blé les collègues dans ce
cas-là nous reviendrons à la procédure
d'initiative parlementaire une
proposition de loi a été adoptée au
Sénat il suffit que l'Assemblée
nationale la vote en l'état en l'
et nous irons au référendum et pour ce
qui ah bah si ma ma compréhension de la
Constitution est que dès lors qu'une
proposition de loi a été adoptée dans
les mêmes termes par les deux assemblées
la suite et le référendum c'est la
Constitution le le le président de la
République ou le gouvernement peuvent
choisir entre le référendum ou le
Congrès lorsqu'il s'agit d'un projet de
loi constitutionnel donc d'initiative
gouvernementale s'il s'agit d'une
initiative parlementaire c'est
systématiquement le référendum et je ne
vois pas comment le président de la
République pourrait décider de ne pas
recourir au référendum après que la que
nous ayons satisfait à la double
exigence d'un vote conforme dans les
deux assemblées et en ce qui nous
concerne parlementaire militantes
féministes défenseuse du libre choix
nous n'avons pas peur du référendum donc
ce n'est pas notre premier choix mais si
nous devions arriver là nous irons voilà
ces choses sont clair
et j'espère que ça va infuser dans les
réflexions de nos collègues du Sénat et
enfin dernière chose c'est juste un
petit rappel historique l'ARIPA a été
créé en 2016 al c'est pas que je sois
sourcilleuse et cetera mais de temps en
temps de temps en temps se rappeler
qu'elle a été considérablement améliorée
depuis 2006 que elle a été le travail
engagé a été poursuivi l'ARIPA est a
été fourni de nouveaux collaborate
des nouvelles lois sont venues mais elle
a été créée en
2016 bah on fait toutes les questions et
vous répondez ensuite donc Joceline
Antoine et qui sera suivi par olivierre
Richard merci madame la présidente
monsieur le garde des saau je vais être
très bref puisque vous avez répondu en
grande partie à ce que je voulais ce
dont je voulais vous entretenir sur
l'actualité actu de la directive
européenne sur les violences faites aux
femmes dont l'article 5 prévoit
d'instaurer donc la une définition
pénale unique de viol fondé sur la sur
la notion de
consentement l'opposition de la France
me semble quand même un petit peu
problématique parce qu'elle rentre en
contradiction avec la Convention
d'istanbou du Conseil de l'Europe que la
France a
signé en 2014 et qui impose aux
États-membres de criminaliser les actes
sexuels non consenti alors bien sûr il
ne
s'agit que d'une
convention euh j'ai bien entendu votre
exposé sur l'aspect de la démission
juridique du viol mais bon afin de
protéger au mieux les victime ne
conviendrait-il pas de garder les
notions de menace violence contrainte et
surprise tel que le prévoit notre droit
et qui
effectivement est un des plus
contraignants d'Europe euh mais
également de considérer en plus que
l'absence de consentement est légalement
constitutive d'un viol parce que dans
l'état d'esprit des victimes c'est quand
même pas tout à fait la même
chose et je pense que ça encouragerait
aussi les femmes à porter plin plus
facilement dans la démarche
psychologique voilà je vous remercie
Olivia Richard merci présidente monsieur
le garde des saau sénatrice des Français
établieur de France je suis très
sensible ible au rayonnement de la
France sur la scène
internationale et dès lors l'inscription
de l'IVG dans la Constitution me paraît
me paraîtrait être un symbole très
fort et une réaffirmation d'un
attachement à des valeur humanistes
indispensa donc je voterai bien entendu
ce texte en espérant qu'il qu'il arrive
vite et qu'il ne fasse pas l'objet d'une
procédure plus compliquée même si en
effet elle serait possible euh donc les
Françaises établies hors de France
pardon de de parler d'elle parce que
c'est une population qui est lointaine
mécnue mais comment accéder à l'IVG dans
des pays où c'est totalement interdit ça
implique de rentrer en France pourquoi
le Sénat avait adopté un amendement à
l'occasion de la discussion budgétaire
qui a disparu à la faveur d'un 493 qui
prévoyait la possibilité de rapatrier
les femmes qui devaient rentrer en
France pour bénéficier de cela euh vous
le savez il y a des délais contraints je
regrette la disparition de cette
disposition euh deuxième chose nous
avons entendu le le Premier ministre
parlait de la possibilité de porter
plainte en ligne euh là encore des ce
serait très précieux pour les femmes
françaises à l'étranger qui peuvent pas
aller porter plainte au consulat
et ça pose néanmoins le problème nous
avons des conventions international qui
interdisent de déplacer les enfants de
façon euh j'allais dire unilatérale donc
un mari violent car généralement ce sont
les maris qui sont violents euh a des
droits sur ses enfants de
façon en tout cas en fonction de la
droit la loi locale mais même du droit
français et donc une femme qui tente de
rentrer en France pour échapper à son
bourreau emmène ses enfants et se
retrouve euh
elle-même coupable d'un d'un déplacement
illicite d'enfant euh les agents du
ministère des Affaires étrangères plus
particulier le Bureau d'aide aux
familles en lien avec votre are
ministère tente d'expliquer aux
autorités françaises locales lors du
retour que non ce ne sont pas des
enlèvements non c'est une mise à l'abri
et néanmoins il faut une évolution
législative pour sécuriser et
permettre le retour en France de ces
femmes qui parfois n'ont même pas de
famille hein se retrouvent totalement
isolé les Français l'étrangers sont loin
d'être tous des expatrié
euh lorsqu'elle le sont c'est-à-dire on
a encore beaucoup de femmes qui suivent
leur mari à l'étranger elles dépendent
pour la légalité de leur situation la
régularité de leur situation du visa du
conjoint qui trouve encore un moyen de
pression supplémentaire puisque retirer
le passeport ne suffit plus euh pour
fragiliser leur situation et il m'a été
rapporté des cas dans certains pays euh
où en cas de séparation bien sûr la
femme perd son visa et doit repartir
mais où les enfants sont invités à
rester bon euh d'autres cas encore où le
mari quitte la femme quitte le pays
dénonce le visa de son épouse et donc de
ses enfants qui se retrouvent
irrégulierers et doivent payer une
asrein journ bref il y a des situations
inextricables et tout est encore pire à
l'étranger voilà merci pour votre
attention je vous laisse la parole pour
répondre à ces nombreuses questions
monsieur le
ministre il est déjà voilà merci madame
le Président
madame la sénatrice billon
euh d'abord merci pour vos gentils mots
à propos de
notre collaboration efficace et
effective le
texte que vous avez que vous nous avez
présenté et qui a permis me semble-t-il
de faire beaucoup évoluer les choses
nous avons dit clairement
euh
que un homme ne peut plus dire qu'une
gamine de 14 ans était
consentante exception faite de notre
petit
amendement Roméo Roméo et Juliette
euh qui a été disons-le débattu euh la
notion de danger sur sur l'ordonnance de
de protection est une exigence
constitutionnelle alors il faut qu'on
trouve n pas si simple que cela mais je
pense que nous avons trouvé un équilibre
euh un équilibre entre les atteintes aux
libertés fondamentales parce que ça va
très vite et que il y a se poser la
question du contradictoire parce que bon
euh on prend quelqu'un par la peau du
dos on le on le vire du domicile
conjugal euh il faut qu'il y ait aussi
euh matière à ce que le contradictoire
puisse à un moment s'exercer qu'il
puisse faire valoir ses droits donc il y
avait l'équilibre indispensable entre
une une une une atteinte aux liberté
fondamental sans déclaration de
culpabilité je le rappelle parce que on
est dans de l'extrême urgence donc le
procureur intervient Phe de
contradictoire ensuite et la Cour de
cassation a dit je vous transmettrai la
décision que la
constitutionnalité était au fond
subordonné à l'existence d'un danger
alors ensuite vient la définition de ce
qui est un danger
j'entends tout ce que vous me dites mais
euh ce cette proposition de loi doit
doit être examiné dans les dans les
heures qui viennent devait dans les
jours qui viennent un mois de mars ça a
été reporté mais il n'était pas exclus
qu'elle soit débattue dès hier et puis
pour cause d'embouteillage si si si
j'ose dire ça a été reporté au mois de
mars mais ce n'est pas à vous que je
vais dire qu'il y aura aussi un travail
parlementaire et qui l'aura aussi mais
comme
d'habitude pour objet d'enrichir le
texte
bon
potentiellement donc tout ça va être
discuté la recherche pour moi c'est
celle d'un équilibre sans perdre de
l'efficacité je dois dire que jusqu'à
maintenant on a de façon drastique
réduit les
délais et il est indispensable oui qu'on
puisse intervenir en cas de de de danger
d'urgence
avec les difficultés de définir des
concepts comme cela mais moi je ne doute
pas une seule seconde que nous allons y
parvenir et que cette ordonnance
ultra rapide est au fond d'une une
grande nécessité et et et nous le savons
bon sur la médecine légale c'est c'est
j'ai eu des échanges déjà avec la ma
collègue chargé de la santé bon on est
là sur de de l'interministériel
effectivement on a beaucoup de choses à
renforcer je je je il y a ce sujet que
vous évoquez il y a le sujet de la
psychiatrie également est un sujet
majeur très imbriqué
avec la détention par exemple mais aussi
la
prévention donc là-dessus on est en
train de de de travailler on a à
l'esprit l'un et l'autre que il est
indispensable que nous
renforcions tout ce qui
permet aux femmes victimes d'avoir accès
à la médecine
égal vous m'avez interrogé encore sur la
la féminisation de la magistrature bien
alors si si j'étais cynique ce que je ne
suis pas je vous dirais laissons faire
les choses quand je vais aux prestations
de serment
des auditeur de justice je suis toujours
surpris quand il y a un garçon qui vient
faire le petit selfie il y en a plus
c'est pratiquement exclusivement féminin
hein le barreau s'oriente aussi vers
cela bon et moi en ce qui me
concerne j'ai proposé au Conseil
supérieur de la
magistrature des procureurs procureurs
généraux qui sont des femmes bon et je
dois vous dire je sais pas si c'est
rassurant mais c'est une réalité mon
cabinet est
composé très majoritairement de femmes
magistrat et enfin pour être un peu plus
sérieux et répondre à vos préoccupations
dans le PJ que vous avez voté on a pris
un certain nombre de dispositions pour
que non seulement les femmes qui sont
magistrates soient magistrates
évidemment mais qu'ell puissent accéder
évidemment à au
postes hiérarchique qui leur sont d
voilà ce que je peux vous répondre
madame madame Rossignol madame Rossignol
oui har pas rendons rendons à César mais
oui temps temps ben voilà non mais et
d'ailleurs non mais je je n'en ai pas
fait une appropriation
euh mensongère concédez-le moi j'ai
évoqué haripa je oui il me plaît de vous
dire à cet instant que je sais qui est à
l'origine d'aripa
euh vous posez des moi moi vous savez je
suis je demande qu'à être convaincu
donc la question des des des des
cours
spécialisés vous avez évoqué le terror
le terrorisme vous avez évoqué le
stupéfiant bande
organisé
je suis saisi d'une question en ce
moment on ne rien vous cacher parce que
on me dit mais quand on trafique des
stupes en bande organisé c'est la cour
d'assise spéciale mais quand deux
trafiquants de stup
s'entretuent c'est le la cour d'assise
traditionnelle est-ce qu'il y a pas là
Monsieur le Ministre une difficulté et
on réfléchit là-dessus et de la même
façon on peut réfléchir à ce que vous
dites pas maintenant je ouais ouais mais
j'entends bien mais
là aussi l'équilibre est toujours
difficile à trouver parce que on m'a
déjà beaucoup
reproché n'était pas à l'initiative de
ça mais j'ai j'ai j'ai ensuite
évidemment été totalement engagé sur les
cours criminales départementales pour
les raisons que j'ai évoqué m'a beaucoup
reproché de vouloir tuer la cour
d'assise traditionnelle à cela je
répondais que j'avais renforcé la
souveraineté
populaire puisque j'avais exigé que dans
le cadre de la définition d'une
culpabilité il y ait une majorité de
jurist qui n'était plus le cas
bon alors il faut aussi qu'on garde
cette cour d'assise parce que il est
important dans une grande démocratie que
au fond le peuple au nom de qui on rend
la justice puisse y participer mais mais
ce que vous dites mérite
expertise ouais je j'entends j'entends
c'est vrai que des êtres humains en
bande organisé bon l'idée de de ces
juridictions spécialisées c'est pour
protéger les jurés d'ailleurs hein bon
on a eu un certain nombre d'affaires où
les magistrats professionnels euh on a
considéré qu'ils
étaient mieux à même de faire face à une
criminalité du du haut du spectre comme
on dit en langage technocratique c'estàd
que on avait eu vent de ce que des jurés
pouvait être menacé d'ailleurs on avait
parfois la difficulté qui était de les
réunir euh voilà et on a vu des
défections d'ailleurs donc je suis
opposé à rien a priori on va on va
réfléchir on peut même réfléchir
ensemble vous savez je le redis madame
Rossin je vousou l'ai déjà dit que la
porte de la Chancellerie est est
ouverte bah oui je sais non mais vous
vous dites AR pas et moi je dis la porte
est ouverte chacun dit son petit truc
aussi parce que c'est vrai bon voilà
hein euh
sur la question madame la sénatrice
Antoine
de de
l'Europe bon d'ailleurs c'est une
question qui est aussi posée par Madame
Rossignol qu'il faudrait pas ajouter
dans le texte que le viol est une
relation non consentie je je alors
d'emblé mais sans y avoir réfléchi
davantage je pense que la définition du
viol telle que nous l'avons dans notre
code pénal nécessairement mais
implicitement rappelle le défaut de
consentement puisque on parle de
violence on parle de de de surprise par
exemple de contraintte bon bien sûr donc
ce sont des choses qui sont me
semble-t-il claires je suis pas
insensible à
l'idée d'être peut-être plus pédagogue
auprès des victimes ça se réfléchit moi
je ne suis contre rien mais ce que je
veux réaffirmer ici parce que j'ai vu
toute une polémique
monter que
le garde des saau entre autres
gouvernement auquel il
appartient serait rétrograde frileux sur
ces questions
bon c'est pas un
argument dont on peut faire son beurre
électoraliste ma préoccupation je l'ai
dit c'est la vôre aussi je suis vraiment
très heureux de de d'avoir entendu ce
que vous aviez à dire sur cette question
c'est faisons attention qui tropérain
parfois malembrasse et au fond vouloir
protéger le dire et puis se voir au
final opposer une décision qui serait
une décision qui s'imposerait à tous de
la Cour de justice je l'aurais dit c'est
une question de compétence et j'ai j'ai
trouvé un
peu pas utiliser les grands mots les
mots qui fchent mais un peu malhonnête
la présentation qui a parfois été faite
des
choses au fond j'entendais nous nous
avons les solution
nous nous protégeons les femmes nous et
nous et nous et le gouvernement est en
retrait non pas du tout le gouvernement
il dit faisons très attention à ce que
ce que nous essayons de de construire au
quotidien ayant encore des failles ayant
encore beaucoup de boulot et c'est un
combat qui malheureusement n'est jamais
terminé n'aboutissent pas à pire que ce
que nous avons aujourd'hui dans le cadre
d'une législation qui sait ce que c'est
que le viol qu'il le reprime et qu'il le
réprime de façon plus sévère que les
autres pays européens alors faire de la
petite polache là-dessus ça m'a un peu
chagriné parce que je le redis
d'ailleurs vous savez si vous êtes au
faitte du
sujet qu' a de vraies discussions de
juristes de très très haut niveau la
question c'est celle de la compétence et
enen déplais à certains bah cette
question là elle mérite quand même
d'être examiné on peut pas faire
n'importe quoi moi je n'ai pas envie
évidemment que on fasse n'importe quoi
et qu'au fond le résultat obtenu soit
pire que ce que nous avons madame
Richard la la la plainte en ligne pour
l'étranger n'est pas prévu maintenant
mais il faut qu'on y travaille et
alors les les sujets que vous évoquez
sont pour moi et pour le ministère un
casse-tête sagisse des questions
d'adoption alors vous me dites changer
la législation alors la difficulté c'est
que notre législation n'a pas vocation
s'appliquer dans des pays souverain et
donc il y a la voie évidemment de
l'évolution législative pour faciliter
le parcours de femmes qui veulent
revenir en France tout ça on peut
l'envisager et moi si vous avez des
propositions à me faire je suis tout à
fait preneur en revanche on est
davantage sur du du du du traité futtil
bilatéral multilatéral pour essayer
d'obtenir aussi de nos partenaires une
forme de réciprocité par exemple et de
permettre que une femme qui revient avec
ses enfant parfois d'ailleurs dans le
cadre d'une décision de justice rendue
en France par un
un juge français ne fasse pas l'objet de
tracasserie tracasserie c'est doucement
euphémique hein vous vous vous l'avez
dit j'étais confronté à une question de
de d'adoption c'est un véritable
casse-tê parce que on ne peut pas
opposer si j'ose dire même si on essaie
de le faire dans la dans la discussion
dans la tractation on peut pas
opposer notre législation à d'autres
pays mais ça m'intéresse beaucoup que
vous veniez me faire part des des choses
qui à votre sens pourrai évoluer pour
permettre à nos compatriotes qui sont à
l'étranger euh d'être l'ti si j'ose dire
à meilleur enseigne
euh à qui dois-je encore répondre et
bien c'est vous madame la Présidente
c'est à moi qu'il revient de conclure et
en fait ce sera pas quelques questions
mais plutôt quelques remarques à la
suite de cette audition que je m'étais
noté au fur et et à mesure de votre
intervention vous avez évoqué la justice
patrimoniale il trouve que c'est une
proposition que probablement notre
groupe devrait porter le groupe Union
centriste en tout cas il fait partie des
choix qui nous ont été proposés et le
vote est en cours et j'espère en tout
cas personnellement j'y suis très
favorable et j'ai voté pour ce texte et
je crois que nous avons de bonnes
chances qu'il puisse être inscrit dans
une niche prochaine de l'Union centriste
sur les pôles viv j'avais quelque chose
à à préciser finalement pour être allé
en Espagne et comme comme vous le dites
c'est toujours l'exemple finalement
quand je vois les pôles puisque
aujourd'hui je suis invité dans un
certain nombre de juridiction pour voir
ses pôles se mettre en place ou
rencontrer les présidents de tribunaux
ou les procureurs généraux nous allons
plus loin finalement que ce que fait
l'Espagne puisque en Espagne même si
c'est dans un même bâtiment le pénal et
le civil ne se parlent pas alors que là
le pénal et le civil vont se parler pour
aller effectivement dans le sens que
nous souhaitions c'est que ce soit une
une affaire globale qui soit traitée
dans toutes ces dimensions femmes hommes
enfant et
effectivement nous sommes nous nous
allons plus loin et et je suis très
heureuse de faire ce ce Tour de France
en ce moment un petit élément qui m'a
été signalé vous savez qu'il y a
toujours des gens qui nous suivent à
l'extérieur sur le fait qu'il y a eu un
petit un sondage qui a été fait sur le
contrôle coercitif et de savoir s'il
devrait faire partie de notre arsenal
pénal en tout cas il semblerait 96 % des
personnes soient prononcées pour je
pense que de toute façon c'est
effectivement un sujet à travailler
puisque l'avantage du contrôle coercitif
et je sais que nos gendarmes de liyum
par exemple s'y forment c'est ce sont
des éléments de preuve pour bien montrer
qu'il n'y a pas d'égalité il n'y a pas
de parole contre parole mais bien un
auteur qui a mis en place tout un
système pour pouvoir mettre sa victime
sous emprise et on fait porter c'est un
peu pour ça que j'étais heureuse de vous
entendre sur le viol on fait porter sur
l'auteur la responsabilité de ces actes
et non pas sur la victime à savoir si
elle était sous emprise si machin si
truc
euh sur et d'ailleurs puisque nous
parlons de formation assez sujet là je
pense que ces formations aideront aussi
beaucoup à mieux poursuivre les viols et
à probablement avoir un petit peu moins
de classements sans suite dont on on dit
souvent que effectivement c'est manque
de preuve mais
parfois en tout cas j'ai un un cas bien
précis en tête où globalement on est à
peu près assuré quand même que le
monsieur s'est très mal comporté et
probablement pas qu'avec la personne qui
a osé aller porter plainte le classement
sans suite est très gênant parce que bah
globalement si on poursuit pas on sait
qu'il va continuer et donc c'est vrai
que ce manque de preuve ou de de le le
le fait de pas creuser et je pense que
en étant mieux for mais on trouve plus
d'éléments également sur le comportement
des auteurs sur la remarque de notre
collègue Laurence Rossignol
effectivement que je comprends
parfaitement parce que le procès entre
autes French bukqué et en tout cas tout
ce qui est porno ça mérite d'être
franchement publque qu'il ait une grosse
publicité autour pour montrer que non on
ne fait pas n'importe quoi et que oui le
porno c'est de la violence en tout cas
dans dans ces sujets là donc voilà et
pour conclure sur l'ARIPA alors moi
j'avais déjà fait la même réflexion sur
les maisons France service dont je
voyais que parfois certains se
gargarisaient et en oubliant qu'il y
avait les maisons de service au public
était ouverte quand même depuis quelques
années
euh mais je voulais et voilà donc des
choses qui se qui se développe euh donc
effectivement rendons à César je sur
laaripa vous avez mentionné
effectivement des montants nous y
reviendrons quand nous remettrons notre
rapport sur les familles monoparentales
euh puisque on se rend compte qu'en fait
aujourd'hui il traite beaucoup le flux
des nouveaux entrants et assez peu le
stock ancien et donc nous ne savons pas
aujourd'hui vraiment mesurer le nombre
de de pensions alimentaires qui
n'étaient pas payé et qui aujourd'hui
pourrait être recouvré par rapport au
stock donc voilà nous demanderons très
probablement d'avoir une petite analyse
sur le sujet vous voyez ce n'étaiit pas
vraiment des questions mais des
compléments d'information ou de sur nos
des compléments d' formation également
sur nos travaux donc il me reste
vraiment à vous remercier du temps que
vous nous avez consacré de
l'exhaustivité des sujets que vous avez
pu évoquer et puis bah puisque vous avez
ouvert votre porte à de nombreux membres
de la délégation je ne peux que vous
dire à très
bientôt